NEW YORK TO TAKE OVER.
HEY COMMISSION.
>> Sean:TO BE TOO TOO HIGH BEEN
MATT, WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
HUGE BREAKING DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT AND THE QUEST FOR EQUAL
JUSTICE AND THE TRUTH OF JOHN
SOLOMON HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE
CONSIDERING FILING CRIMINAL
REFERRALS AGAINST MUELLER
PROSECUTORS AND NOW THIS IS
MAJOR NEWS, JOHN SOLOMON WILL BE
HERE TO BREAK IT DOWN, BUT FIRST
WE BEGAN THE PRESIDENT MAKING
HISTORY IN THE WORLD’S BIGGEST
DEMOCRACY JUST A FEW HOURS AGO.
HE LANDED IN NEW DELHI, INDIA,
WHERE 100,000 PLUS LOCALS LINED
UP ALONG THE PRESIDENT’S
MOTORCADE ROUTE AND ANOTHER
100,000 FILLING IN THE LARGEST
CRICKET ARENA AND 110, 120,000
WITHIN A ROUSING SPEECH VOWING
AMERICA WILL ALWAYS BE FAITHFUL
TO LOYAL FRIENDS LIKE THE INDIAN
PEOPLE.
WE WILL HAVE MUCH MORE COMING UP
IN THE PROGRAM BUT NOW LET’S
TURN OUR ATTENTION BACK HOME
WHERE WE HAVE A BUSY WEEKEND TO
UNPACK, BERNIE SANDERS IS NOW
THE UNQUESTIONED, UNDISPUTED,
WITHOUT A DOUBT CLEAR FRONT
RUNNER IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY.
ON SATURDAY HE WON NEVADA CAUCUS
BY A WHOPPING 26 POINTS.
HE NOW HAS A MAJOR HEAD ESTEEM
AND MOMENTUM ROLLING INTO THIS
COMING SATURDAY, SOUTH CAROLINA
PRIMARY.
ONE WEEK FROM TOMORROW, SUPER
TUESDAY WHICH TAKES PLACE, WELL
FOR ALL THE WORLD TO SEE.
IT IS NOW GAME-TIME AND THEY GET
THE MINUS.
THE NEXT SEVERAL DAYS, BUCKLE
UP.
WE ARE ABOUT TO WITNESS A
BARE-KNUCKLED POLITICAL BRAWL
INSIDE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
FIGURATIVELY SPEAKING, THE
KNIVES ARE OUT FOR BERNIE AND
OTHERS.
ALREADY, BY THE WAY, IT’S NOT A
PRETTY SIGHT.
AS YOU ALL KNOW.
I ALWAYS TELL YOU EVERY TWO
YEARS, FOUR YEARS WHAT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PLAYBOOK AGAINST
DEMOCRATS?
ALWAYS AROUND IDENTITY POLITICS.
REPUBLICANS -- ISLAMOPHOBIC,
DIRTY AIR WATER AND GRANDMA AND
GRANDPA DOG FOOD AND CAT FOOD,
LET’S SEE, A COUPLE McCARTHY,
DONALD TRUMP LOOK ALIKE WILL
THROW GRANNY OVER THE CLIQUE --
CLIFF.
PRETTY PREDICTABLE BUT BEFORE
THOSE PHONY ADS, THEY GET TO DO
TO EACH OTHER WHAT THEY DO TO
REPUBLICANS EVERY TWO YEARS AND
FOUR YEARS AND THAT IS A TOTAL
SHIFTSCHIFF SHOW KNIFE FIGHT AND
GETTING STARTED.
BERNIE FACING SCRUTINY CENTERED
AROUND DISTURBING PRETTY VILE,
SICK, UGLY ARTICLE THAT HE WROTE
HIMSELF IN 1972.
WE DO HAVE A VIEWER WARNING
ABOUT THIS.
WHAT I AM ABOUT TO SHOW YOU,
WELCOME AT THE BEYOND CREEPY,
BEYOND GRAPHIC.
A PIECE ENTITLED MAN AND WOMEN,
SANDERS WRITES ABOUT VARIOUS
"RAPE FANTASIES" ONE SECTION
WRITING "A WOMAN ENJOYS
INTERCOURSE WITH HER MAN AS
SHE’S FANTASIZING ABOUT BEING
RAPE BY THREE MEN
SIMULTANEOUSLY."
MOVE OVER, CREEPY JOE AND FORMER
MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
IN OTHER WORDS ANOTHER PARAGRAPH
HE WRITES "DO YOU KNOW WHY THE
NEWSPAPER ARTICLES LIKE GIRLS
RAPE BY 14 MEN SELL SO WELL?
TO WHAT INIS ARE THEY APPEALING,
HE WRITES?"
SPEAK FOR YOURSELF.
BEYOND GROSS, WEIRD, REPULSIVE
AND FRANKLY A LEVEL I CAN’T
COMPREHEND.
OF COURSE SANDERS AND HIS
CAMPAIGN DISAVOWING THE ARTICLE
EVEN THOUGH HE WROTE IT
CALLING IT DECADES-OLD ATTEMPT
TO DARK SATIRE.
THIS MIGHT BE THE LEAST, BY THE
WAY, BERNIE’S WORRIES.
BY CALLING HIMSELF A DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST, SOCIALIST
BERNIE SANDERS SPENT DECADES
POWERING AROUND -- PALLING
AROUND WITH VILE, EVIL MURDERERS
SOCIALIST REGIMES -- REGIME --
REGIMES.
WHAT A WONDERFUL HONEYMOON TOOK
HIS WIFE TO FORMER SOVIET UNION
WITH AN INFRASTRUCTURE AND YOUTH
PROGRAMS.
WHO HONEYMOONS IN THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION?
THE FORMER SOVIET UNION?
FORGET ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AND HE HAS HOSTILE PEER OF THE
HOSTILE REGIME THAT IS RUSSIA.
THEY ARE HOSTILE.
COMMUNIST SYSTEM AND
SOVIET UNION WAS A SPECIAL LEVEL
OF EVIL IN AND OF ITSELF.
AND BERNIE, TENS OF MILLIONS OF
POLITICAL DISSIDENTS WERE
MURDERED BY THE VERY SAME SOVIET
GOVERNMENT WHERE HE IS
HONEYMOONING AT THE TIME.
DID HE FORGET ABOUT THE KGB?
TERRORIZING THE ENTIRE
POPULATION?
DID HE FORGET MILLIONS MORE DIED
FROM STARVATION?
DID HE FORGET ABOUT THE BREAD
LINES?
THAT WAS A WAY OF LIFE IN THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION WAITING IN
LINE FOR BASIC NECESSITIES.
OH, MILK COME A WEEK WHEAT,
BREAD, MEDICAL SUPPLIES, ALL IN
SHORT SUPPLIES AND
FAMILIES PACKED INTO TINY,
POORLY MAINTAINED GOVERNMENT
HOUSING AND NEARLY EVERYONE THER
LIVED IN POVERTY AND FEAR EXCEPT
COURSE, THE LEADERS THEMSELVES.
THAT BERNIE SOCIALIST UTOPIA ONE
NOTABLE RUSSIAN AUTHOR MY
POLITICAL PRISONER WROTE "ALL
COMMUNIST PARTIES UPON OBTAINING
POWER AND BECOME COMPLETELY
MERCILESS" AT THE STAGE BEFORE
THEY ACHIEVE POWER, IT IS
NECESSARY TO USE THE GUISES.
WELL SAID.
FOR BERNIE, IS HE THAT STUPID?
FOR ALL OF THESE GUISES?
BY THE WAY HE DID NOT JUST
PRAISE THE SOVIET UNION.
THAT IS ONLY ONE EXAMPLE.
1985 HE VISITED NICARAGUA’S
BRUTAL LEADER AT THE TIME,
DANIEL WEALTH OR TAKE UP TO
CELEBRATE THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE SOCIALIST REVOLUTION THERE.
BERNIE CALLED ORTEGA AN
IMPRESSIVE GUY.
EVEN PRAISED THE COUNTRY’S BREAD
LINES ACCORDING TO BERNIE AND
THIS VIDEO, SPENDING HOURS IN
LINE FOR A CHANCE TO FEED YOUR
STARVING FAMILY IS A GOOD THING.
WHAT?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT’S FUNNY, SOMETIMES
AMERICAN JOURNALIST TALK ABOUT
HOW BAD THE COUNTRY IS AND
PEOPLE ARE LINING UP FOR FOOD.
THAT IS A GOOD THING.
IN OTHER COUNTRIES, PEOPLE DON’T
LINE UP FOR FOOD.
THE RICH GET THE FOOD AND THE
OTHERS PULL UP THE DECK.
>> Tucker: IF YOU THINK THAT
IS BAD IT GETS WORSE.
1989 BERNIE VISITED COMMUNIST
CUBA WHERE HEAPING PRAISE ON THE
CASTRO REGIME PRAISING FREE
HEALTH CARE, FREE EDUCATION,
FREE HOUSING.
AND JUST THIS WEEKEND, SANDERS
CONTINUED TO PRAISE CUBA
SOCIALIST DICTATORSHIP, LAUDING
ITS LITERACY RATE.
HOW CAN YOU BE THIS
DISCONNECTED?
TAKE A LOOK.
THE AUTHORITARIAN NATURE OF
CUBA.
IT IS UNFAIR FOR EVERYTHING THAT
IS BAD.
YOU KNOW, FIDEL CASTRO CAME INTO
OFFICE AND YOU KNOW WHAT HE DID?
A MASSIVE LITERACY PROGRAM.
IS THAT A BAD THING?
WE CONDEMN THAT.
>> Tucker: AND OTHERS
MURDERED.
LET ME EDUCATE THE VILLAGE IDIOT
WITH HARD COLD FACTS ABOUT THE
EVIL REGIME OF THE CASTRO
BROTHERS.
A LAB REGIME THAT BERNIE
CONTINUES TO PRAISE.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THEY TURNED
CARIBBEAN PARADISE INTO A
SOCIALIST STARTING IN THE LATE
50s.
THE REPUBLIC OF CUBA SEES TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PRIVATE FIRMS,
PRIVATE HOMES AND PRIVATE
BUSINESSES.
THEN THEY BEGAN WITH CASTRO’S
POLITICAL ENEMIES.
THEN THEY EXPANDED TO
COMPENSATIONS NATIONWIDE.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF CUBANS
HAD TO FLEE THEIR HOME COUNTRY
TO THE UNITED STATES.
BY THE WAY, THEY WERE THE LUCKY
ONES.
UPWARDS OF 140,000 POLITICAL
DISSIDENTS WERE MURDERED BY THE
SOCIALIST GOVERNMENT IN CUBA.
THOUSANDS MORE THROWN IN PRISON.
MANY TIMES FOR DECADES AND THEY
THREW AWAY THE KEY.
TODAY EVERYONE IN CUBA LIVES
UNDER THE OPPRESSIVE THUMB OF
THE CASTRO REGIME TOO.
CASTRO IS GONE BUT HIS BROTHER
FOLLOWS THROUGH.
THERE IS NO FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS.
THERE IS NO FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
THERE IS NO FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT.
IT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
INTERNET IN 2015 AND ONLY 5%
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
THAT IS HEAVILY CENSORED AND
ACCORDING TO HUMAN RIGHTS
GROUPS, SURVEILLANCE, BEATINGS,
ARBITRARY DETENTION, PUBLIC ACTS
OF REPUDIATION ARE STILL BEING
USED BY THE ACUMEN -- CUBAN
GOVERNMENT.
MEANWHILE CUBAN SOCIAL ECONOMIC
SYSTEM AND OTHER AGILE FAILURE,
1994 CUBAN FACING WIDESPREAD
STARVATION LEADING TO AN EXODUS
2019 THE GOVERNMENT STARTED
RATIONING FOOD.
HUMANS FACE LONG LINES FOR
SIMPLE BASICS, YOU KNOW,
CHICKEN, FLOUR, SOAP.
AVERAGE SALARY IN CUBA, A
WHOPPING $20 A MONTH.
BUT YOU GET FREE HEALTH CARE.
MEANWHILE FIDEL CASTRO, HE HAD
AN ESTIMATED NET WORTH OF AROUND
BUT SURE, CONGRATS, SOCIAL
BERNIE.
SOCIAL LITERACY RATES ARE REAL
HIGH, THE HEALTH CARE MICHAEL
MOORE TELLS US IS ONE TO BE
ENVIED IN THE WORLD.
NOW, IT SEEMS LIKE IT IS HE THAT
WANTS TO BRING THAT SYSTEM TO
THE UNITED STATES.
IN OTHER WORDS, BERNIE IS
TALKING ABOUT NATIONALIZING
HEALTH CARE, MEDICARE FOR ALL.
DON’T FORGET ALSO THEY WANT TO
NATIONALIZE THE ENERGY INDUSTRY.
DON’T FORGET THEY WANT A HOSTILE
TAKEOVER OF ALL OIL AND GAS
COMPANIES.
BAD IDEA, ESPECIALLY HANDING IT
OVER TO PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
ELIMINATE ALL OIL AND GAS, WHICH
IS THE LIFE OF THE WORLD ECONOMY
AND FRANKLY THE GREATEST
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY
AMERICAN IF WE TAP THE VAST
RESOURCES WE HAVE HERE.
IT IS ALSO GOOD FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY BECAUSE WE DON’T HAVE
TO GO TO COUNTRIES THAT HATE OUR
GUTS AND BEGGED FOR THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY OR GET
INVOLVED IN FOREIGN
ENTANGLEMENTS OVER THE FREE FLOW
OF OIL AND MARKET PRICES.
HE WANTS FREE COLLEGE, HE WANTS
FREE CHILD CARE, GOVERNMENT PAID
LEAVE, GREEN NEW DEAL AND BY THE
WAY THE BUDGET, FEDERAL BUDGET
IS AROUND $4.5 TRILLION.
BUT BERNIE IS PROPOSING
$100 TRILLION IN NEW SPENDING
OVER THAT 10-YEAR PERIOD.
FOR SOMEBODY TO GET AND HAVE A
CODE, HOW WILL WE PAY FOR ALL
THESE GREAT GOVERNMENT RUN
PROGRAMS?
BERNIE IS NOT EVEN SURE, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> DO YOU HAVE A PRICE TAG FOR
ALL OF THIS?
>> WE DO.
THE PRICE TAG IS, IT WILL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS IN THE
CURRENT SYSTEM GO.
I THINK IT IS $30 TRILLION.
>> THAT IS JUST FOR MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
>> DO YOU HAVE A PRICE TAG FOR
ALL OF THESE?
>> NO, I DON’T.
>> YOU MENTION PUBLIC COLLEGE
TUITION FREE AND CANCELING
STUDENT AT.
>> THAT IS CORRECT, THAT IS WHAT
I WANT TO DO.
WE PAY FOR THAT FOR A MODEST TAX
ON WALL STREET.
>> BUT YOU DON’T KNOW THE TOTAL
PRICE, BUT YOU KNOW HOW IT WILL
BE PAID FOR IT.
HOW DO YOU KNOW IF IT WILL BE
PAID FOR IF YOU DON’T KNOW HOW
MUCH THE PRICE IS?
I CANNOT RATTLE OFF EVERY NICKEL
AND EVERY DIME.
>> Tucker: BERNIE, LET ME HELP
YOU OUT.
YOU NEED HELP?
I’M HAPPY TO BUY THAT ADVOCATE
AND GET YOU A CALCULATOR.
WE WILL BRING YOU UP TO THE YEAR
2022 OUT OF THE NICKELS AND
DIMES YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
HERE.
NOW, I THINK IF YOU WANT TO BE
PRESIDENT, BERNIE YOU MIGHT WANT
TO LEARN BASIC FUNDAMENTAL MATH.
$93 TRILLION FOR THE NEW GREEN
DEAL IN TEN YEARS.
$32 TRILLION, YOUR ESTIMATE,
ELIZABETH WARREN’S $52 TRILLION
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
THOSE TWO PROGRAMS COST OVER
$100 TRILLION.
WE WON’T TAKEN $50 TRILLION AND
THAT 10-YEAR PERIOD.
THE MAD DASH MATH DOES NOT ADD
UP AND THE ONLY WAY TO FUND THIS
MASSIVE EXPANSION OF YOUR
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE COMPENSATION
PRIVATE PROPERTY LIKE YOUR
FRIENDS IN CUBA OR NICARAGUA OR
INVOLVED IMPURE IF YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT A WEALTH TAX, WHAT
IS A WEALTH TAX?
NATIONALIZING HUGE INDUSTRIES.
YOU WILL TAKE THEM OVER?
BERNIE ADMITTED RAISING TAXES ON
EVERYONE MAKING OVER $29,000 A
YEAR.
THIS IS PRETTY SCARY STUFF.
IT WOULD DEVASTATE OUR ECONOMY.
IT WOULD DEVASTATE CAPITALISM AS
WE KNOW IT.
THE WEALTH AND PROSPERITY THAT
WE KNOW AS AMERICA, THE ENVY OF
THE WORLD, AND MAKE BERNIE, YOU
HAVE TO GIVE HIM CREDIT.
HE IS BEING HONEST WITH
COUNTERPARTS WHO ARE TRYING TO
HIDE WHO THEY REALLY ARE BECAUSE
IN REALITY, ALL OF THE
CANDIDATES THAT ARE RUNNING ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE SHARE
SIMILAR IDEALS.
EVERY ONE OF THEM BUYS AND TOO
MUCH OF THIS NONSENSE IN
DIFFERENT VARIATIONS.
OPEN BORDERS, ELIMINATING WHAT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT LATE-TERM
ABORTION HERE THIS IS YOUR NEW
RADICAL EXTREME SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT I HAVE
BEEN WARNING YOU ABOUT.
THEY ALL WANT SOME VERSION OF
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
SOME VERSION OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
SOME VERSION OF STUDENT LOAN
FORGIVENESS.
DOES IT WORK RETROACTIVELY, I
PAID MY MONEY BACK.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE, FREE HOUSING,
FREE MEDICINE, FREE MEDICAL
CARE, FREE HEALTHY FOOD, FREE
VACATIONS, AND A GUARANTEED
GOVERNMENT JOB.
NONE OF THEM HAVE ANY IDEA HOW
THEY WILL PAY FOR ANY OF THIS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE AT ALL COME ALL
THE DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT WANT TO RADICALLY
TRANSFORM THIS COUNTRY,
ACCUMULATED MORE WEALTH THEN
ADVANCE THE HUMAN CONDITION MORE
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND.
THEY WANT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO CONTROL EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR
LIFE, LIKE BLOOMBERG, WHAT YOU
CAN DRINK, THE AMOUNT OF SALT
YOU CAN PUT ON YOUR FOOD.
WHETHER YOU WANT AND
E-CIGARETTE, FOR CRYING OUT
LOUD.
THEY WANT TO STRIP YOU OF YOUR
RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS AND
COMPENSATE YOUR EARNINGS
BASICALLY AFTER YOU PAY 50,
$0.55, $0.56 OF EVERY DOLLAR YOU
MAKE.
THEY WANT ANOTHER BITE OF THE
APPLE TO LEGALIZE STEALING AND
BY THE WAY, EVEN AFTER YOU PAY
YOUR THIS GOOD TORY TAXES AND
AGAIN IF YOU ARE SMART ENOUGH TO
SAVE IT YOU CAN TAKE ANOTHER
BITE AND WHEN YOU DIE THEY WANT
HALF OF WHAT YOU HAVE LEFT AGAIN
SO THEY WANT TO LEGALIZE SO THEY
CAN REMAIN IN POWER.
THEY WANT TO DECIDE WHAT YOU
EAT, WHAT YOU SAY, WHERE YOU
LIVE AND HOW YOU MAKE YOUR
LIVING AND HOW MUCH YOU CAN
MAKE.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
IT SHOULD BECAUSE ALL POWERFUL
CENTRAL A STATIST GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN TRIED ALL OVER THE WORLD,
AND IT HAS RESULTED IN EVERY
SINGLE SOLITARY TIME WITHOUT
EXCEPTION INTO NOTHING BUT
SUFFERING AND CARNAGE FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT PROMISE TO HELP SO
MUCH.
SO IT IS TIME TO SEND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MESSAGE AT THE
BALLOT BOX THAT THEY WILL NEVER